Les bruits ambiants dans
une ville comme Montréal peuvent
être une source sérieuse
d'inconfort et même entraîner
des problèmes de santé chez
les résidents.
Pour en atténuer l'impact,
des chercheurs ont analysé
le phénomène, en temps normal,
mais aussi durant le
confinement. Ce qu'ils ont
découvert va vous surprendre.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Quartier des spectacles,
juillet 2019. Catherine
Guastavino et son équipe
prennent des mesures de niveaux
sonores, pendant le Festival
Juste pour rire, à Montréal.
Début juin 2020.
La chercheuse est à nouveau
à l'oeuvre.
Mais cette fois, l'ambiance
sonore est toute autre.
- Pendant le confinement c'était
vraiment un peu trop calme
pour le centre-ville.
On avait l'impression d'être
dans une ville fantôme,
un peu complètement désertée.
- Catherine Guastavino est
chercheuse en psycho-acoustique.
Depuis 2003, elle arpente
des quartiers de Montréal,
armée d'un sonomètre
et d'enregistreurs.
Elle mesure les niveaux de
bruits, identifie leurs sources,
puis questionne les résidents
comme les passants.
Son but : rendre la ville plus
agréable, d'un point
de vue sonore.
(bruits divers)
Encerclés de thermopompes et
de climatiseurs, de véhicules
en tous genres, de chantiers
de construction, de drones ou
d'avions qui volent au-dessus de
leurs têtes, les citadins sont
envahis par le bruit.
Les conséquences vont de la
perte de sommeil à l'infarctus,
en passant par les difficultés
d'apprentissage à l'école.
- L'Organisation mondiale de
la santé considère que le
fardeau du bruit en termes
de santé est équivalent à celui
du tabagisme passif.
- Dans le Quartier des
spectacles, Catherine Guastavino
travaille avec la Ville pour
limiter les impacts du bruit
sur le voisinage.
Depuis que la Place des
festivals a été inaugurée
au centre-ville, il y a plus
de 10 ans, les immeubles
résidentiels se sont multipliés
dans le quartier.
Avant la pandémie, les enquêtes
ont montré que les voisins
étaient surtout contrariés par
le bruit après les concerts.
- Finalement, les gens n'étaient
pas trop gênés par les festivals
eux-mêmes, mais plus par la
gestion de la foule après.
Une fois que le concert est
terminé, là, on se retrouve avec
des milliers de personnes
qui vont rejoindre le métro
ou marcher dans les ruelles.
- En juin 2020, la ville
émergeait timidement d'un
premier confinement.
L'absence de foule et le
ralentissement de la circulation
laissaient entendre de nouveaux
bruits dans le quartier.
Comme celui des systèmes de
ventilation des grandes tours.
Les bruits des travaux de
construction avaient repris.
- À niveau égal, je pense que
la plupart des résidents
préféreraient entendre des
concerts, de la musique,
des spectacles de rue,
plutôt que ces bruits
de type mécanique qui sont
très désagréables.
- Catherine Guastavino et
son collègue Romain Dumoulin
ont modélisé la propagation
du bruit autour de
la Place des festivals.
Le modèle tient compte des
différentes sources sonores,
mais aussi de la disposition
et du revêtement des bâtiments
qui réfléchissent le son.
- À la Place des festivals
la majorité des bâtiments sont
très réfléchissants. Les seuls
matériaux, les seules surfaces
qui vont être absorbantes, ça va
être les carrés de pelouse
par exemple. Donc ces carrés-là
on va les identifier et
on va leur donner une propriété
d'absorption.
Et là, on va avoir une idée de
quel va être le bruit qui va
être ressenti par un résident.
On pourrait imaginer, par des
calculs, prévoir quel va être
le bruit dans son logement.
Ça c'est en prenant en compte
l'isolation, la façade.
- Leurs travaux ont permis de
modifier l'orientation de
certaines scènes. Ils ont permis
de choisir des haut-parleurs
plus directifs pour concentrer
l'énergie acoustique vers
les spectateurs et réduire la
propagation vers les voisins.
Ailleurs dans la ville,
les problèmes de bruit sont
plus difficiles à gérer.
- Donc une fois qu'on a
construit, par exemple, si
c'est une garderie au bord
de l'autoroute, il n'y a pas
vraiment de solution miracle.
Et les solutions qu'on va
préconiser dans ces moments-là
sont des solutions comme
des murs antibruit qui sont
très coûteux à installer
et à maintenir.
- La chercheuse croit qu'on ne
tient pas suffisamment compte
du bruit dans l'aménagement
des villes.
- Souvent, il y a des
préoccupations visuelles
qui vont prendre le dessus.
Par exemple, si on pense aux
règlements d'urbanisme à
Montréal, pour tout l'équipement
mécanique, donc les
thermopompes, les unités de
ventilation, de climatisation,
ça ne doit pas être visible
de la rue.
Donc, du coup, on se retrouve
souvent avec ces équipements
à l'arrière, dans les ruelles
vertes et qui peuvent être
très bruyants.
Donc là, on a un décalage entre
un environnement visuel qui
va être très vert, très,
intimiste, très calme et des
équipements très bruyants
qui vont se retrouver dans
ce même environnement.
- Catherine Guastavino milite
pour que la dimension sonore
trouve sa juste place dans
les plans d'urbanisme.
Au même titre qu'on produit des
plans et des images de synthèse,
pour imaginer à quoi pourrait
ressembler une future place
publique ou un immeuble
résidentiel, on pourrait simuler
son environnement sonore,
dès le moment de sa conception.
- Je vais rajouter, sur l'avenue
du Mont-Royal, du trafic.
- Dans son laboratoire
de l'Université McGill,
l'équipe arrive à reproduire
des ambiances sonores,
en trois dimensions.
- Je peux rajouter, alors ça
c'est souvent pas perçu
comme très agréable, une
climatisation assez forte.
- Pour un projet de place
publique prévu à l'angle des
rues Mont-Royal et Mentana,
sur le Plateau Mont-Royal,
l'équipe a fait venir des
volontaires en laboratoire,
pour tester différentes
ambiances sonores.
Étonnamment, un niveau sonore
plus élevé était parfois
jugé plus agréable par
les participants.
Tout dépend de la source.
- On peut rajouter
une fontaine au milieu et
voir ce que ça donne.
On peut imaginer rajouter
un piano en libre-service
dans la rue à droite,
cette fois-ci.
- Le confinement a donné
un nouvel élan aux recherches
de Catherine Guastavino.
Dans plusieurs quartiers,
les résidents se sont
réapproprié leur jardin,
grâce au ralentissement
de la circulation.
Dans le Quartier des spectacles,
le niveau sonore a baissé
jusqu'à 10 décibels pendant la
journée. Cela revient à diviser
le niveau de bruit par 10.
- Mais assez vite, on s'est
retrouvé avec des situations
où les gens nous disaient que
c'était trop calme.
C'était un silence presque
anxiogène pour un centre-ville,
de ne pas avoir
cette activité humaine.
- Comme quoi le silence n'est
pas toujours la solution.
- L'objectif ne devrait
pas être uniquement de réduire
les niveaux sonores, mais
de s'assurer qu'on ait
un environnement de qualité.